cool very cool oh cool no hi welcome to
Friday I read it's like remember when
YouTube used to be that pure my friends
okay well let me figure out how to
clutch a camera again I'll have those
fancy rigs I just have my arms and hope
hi my name is grace Helbig if you don't
know you know you know your life is
different now sorry my brain is a little
manic because when I just shot a video
over there as you can see it's like a
murder scene of content - I'm about to
go to memories place and shoot a bonus
podcast this week if you don't know
memory and I have a podcast called this
might get weird we also have a patreon
for our podcast patreon.com slash this
might get weird every month we do a
bonus podcast that's super fun and
looser than our normal podcast if that's
possible but it's based on like patron
specific questions so if you're
interested at all you can go over there
and contribute to that every month I'm
about to go do that the reason I manic
after recording this bonus podcast
mamrie I'm going to take a red-eye to
Philadelphia because my mother's
birthday is tomorrow
June 1st my younger brother who is
taking a plane from Boston to New Jersey
tomorrow morning and we're going to
surprise my mom for her birthday it's
very exciting to him my younger brother
and myself decided to do this on Tuesday
it's now Friday things are up in the air
my mother hates surprises loves feeling
loved does not like surprises so I
cannot wait to see what her reaction is
going to be oh I have these two pimples
on my cheek so this video is non-stop
relatability Wow cool can I get a nudie
pic hey it's an industry slash total
pervert Joe would you like to come with
me on this journey to surprise my mother
for her can you [ __ ] chill we're
trying to be a [ __ ] narcissist on
camera and leverage my mom's birthday
for content let's go so obviously the
main gift that my brothers and I are
giving to my mother this year for a
birthday is our presence but another
gift that I'm making
my mother has is
[Music]
this merch with my face on it you can
link in the description if you want to
get your own butt like daughter of the
year thank you I will take that award
okay
maybe three about security I spend an
hour talking to my uber driver about my
akina's girlfriend can actually make
their long-distance relationship work he
asked me how much I charge for marriage
counseling so there's that now it's up
to do is my favorite thing in an airport
when I have time before I bought
[Music]
as we plan this perfectly I tried to go
into the Sky Lounge and I couldn't I
wouldn't let me in so I said I went to a
bar I always sleep in a chair and wait
forever little and
and then we get our rectifier oh gosh
Erica rental cars been acquired my
brother's flight who had the shorter one
of the two of us has been delayed an
hour so I got the rental car he hasn't
landed yeah I think I wouldn't try and
go to CBS real quick and get like some
decorations that's the only minor hiccup
I landed at 6:30 a.m. I couldn't get
into a lounge and so I ate two vodka
sodas and a tuna salad wrap at a bar and
I felt gross but on brand and then I
fell asleep in a chair and that also
felt gross and I'm grand let's go get
some birthday decorations this is how
much I love my mom I saw a woman with an
eye patch in the Rite Aid and I got a
giant red bow we're back in Jersey baby
except technically right now we're in
Pennsylvania let's go pick up her
brother we did successfully broken into
my parents home look how easy it is to
rob you mother and now we decorate yeah
look at this look at these two party
professionals tim is scouting a Harding
spot yes this is some good spot yeah you
look great um and then let's see she's
on their way back now
they were just sam's club big day cuz
they're moving that's why their house
looks like this my mom would want me to
let you guys know that because she
doesn't want you guys to think that she
just lives like this all the time so not
only is this I saying happy birthday to
her mom it's kind of a saying goodbye to
this house too birthday first here we go
and approving um
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
we put a lot of tape on the world look
at these guys we came to dinner and they
yep they dressed to impress tonight oh
it wouldn't be a birthday without tarot
cards Andy I did I spilled ranch
dressing earlier oh hi it's Tuesday I've
been back in Los Angeles for a couple
days now and I realized I didn't end
this video because I didn't know this is
gonna be a video but hey here we are
you've seen it and that means that it's
a thing that I've published I don't know
this wasn't dramatic and I didn't I
didn't buy her a Tesla or like pretend
to blow up her house or something
because that's not what I'm about this
is the real level of comfort that I have
with surprises and pranks so I hope you
guys enjoyed it thanks for watching I
don't know how do i turn the camera Oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]